Herkese merhaba Benim sesim biraz Gürbüz
O yüzden mikrofonu bıraktım Öncelikle
Pelin Ben herkes hoş geldi burada olmak
çok güzel ve çok heyecan verici O yüzden
de ben bugün benim Heyecanımı
yatıştıracak bir sözle başlamak
istiyorum bir yerde servantezin bir sözü
var dünya bu kadar çılgınca görünürken
Deliliğin ne olduğunu Kim söyleyebilir
ki hayallerden vazgeçmek Belki de budur
delilik böyle demiş beni tanıyanlar
bilir Ben Hayalperest film ama aynı
zamanda da Maceracı ayakları yere basan
Bir Hayal kırıktım hayatım boyunca odun
günden bu yana her sabah uyandığımda bir
fikir değiştirip koşarak gidip böyle
gözlerimi kocaman açıp benim bu gibi bir
fikrim var Ben bugün bunu uyandım lütfen
aileme hem öğretmenlerim de
arkadaşlarıma çılgınca bakışların
altında kaldım
uzunca yıllar oldu ki şu an 36
yaşındayım hala her sabah uyandığımda
Benim bugün bir fikrim var diye
gittiğimde gelen bir durumda
arkadaşlarıma Lütfen biraz sakinler
misin diye beni böyle bir tık
burada
sınırlardan Can fanus'tan bahsediyoruz
Ben cam fanusu kıran insanlardanım
kendimi Öyle nitelendiriyorum hayatım
boyunca bana bunu yapamazsın dendiğinde
Evet peki deyip dönüp başka kapıdan
başka bir şekilde onu yapmayı denedim
bunlardan bir tanesi
örnek sivilcope sivil topluma gönül
vermiş insanlardan bir tanesi
yıllarca mültecilerle ilgili çalışma
yaptım herkes bana neden mültecilerle
ilgili çalışma yaptı sordu ülkenin böyle
bir sorunu var Ben mültecilere
bekliyorsun Lütfen burada kal bekle
destekleme Hayır desteklemem gerekiyordu
inandığım şey şuydu burada bir sorun var
hayatta karşılaştığımız bir durum var ve
bizim yapmamız gereken şey bu sorunu
büyütmek değil bu sorunu çözdüm ve
çareler getirir
en başta yaptığım şeylerden bir tanesi
şuydu sabaha karşı bir gün bu hikaye
anlatmak benim için biraz travmatik olsa
da bununla başlamak istiyorum Çünkü
dünya korkak bir yer hayalleri kabul
etmeyen bir yer insanların varlığını
kabul etmeyen bir yer ve bir sürü
insanlarda başka insanların hayallerini
kabul etmeden onları Kendi
sınırlarımızda konumlandırmayı öğrenmiş
çaresizlikte yaşıyoruz
birileri sakız odasından İzmir'i Çeşmeye
doğru Botla yola çıkmış 6-7 tane kadın 3
tane erkek 10 tane bebek ve çocuk
o kadar zor ki aslında buraya
gelebilmeleri her birinin o kadar zor ki
Burada tutunabilmelerinin onların da
hayalleri var buradan Türkiye'den gidip
Avrupa'ya gitmek orada iyi şartlar
altında yaşamak hayata değer katmak
fikirlerini sunmak Belki de Piyanist
olmak belki arkadaşa ağır olmak Belki de
romancı olmak istiyorlar ama biz onlara
orada sınırlandırıyoruz ve karaya
almıyoruz Bu benim insanlığımı bu benim
hayata bakışıma ve bu benim sınırlarıma
çok hareket ediyor O yüzden sabaha karşı
4'te gittiğimde ilk iş yok jandarma ile
birlikte Çeşme'de limanda birbirimize
kavga ediyoruz Hayır alamayız Hayır
alabilirsiniz onlar çıkmayacak Çünkü
karaya ayak basan denizden bu ülkede
insanı olmuş oluyor ve mülteci
sınırlarında mülteci haklarına sahip
olmuş oluyor kendimi denize atlarken
herkes şaşırdı Çünkü bir türlü silah var
bir Türkiye konuşuyor Rüyamda mak gibi
bir durum
yoktur hep beraber mültecilerle birlikte
yerlere denize düşen o çocukları doğma
tehlikesiyle boğulma tehlikesiyle gün
yüzüne çıkardı
şaşkınlık bu yaptığına da şaşkındım
bundan 14 sene önce daha küçük bir
yıldız 20'li yaşlı oradayım cesaretim
var tabi bunun yanında aptaldım da var
Hepimiz birlikte o dolmuş çocuklar alıp
Hayata geri döndürmeye çalıştı ilk
yardım eğitimim vardı ilk ilk yardımımı
bir bebeğe suni tenefüsü yaparken Ne
oldu Evet hayatım boyunca bir gönüllüydü
gönüllülüğün arasında kendime tatlı bir
şeylerden biri akut ve ilk yardımdı
çalıştı yaşadık sonra onları aldık
götürdük ve Çeşme Belediyesi ile
projeler vesaireler bunları yaptıktan
sonra güvenlik gitmek konusunda destek
verdim güler'le gitmeleri destek olmak
zorundayız Çünkü insanların hayallerine
destek olmaktan benim hayallerimde
destek olan çok insan olmadı Ben
genellikle kazıyarak ve çırpılarak o
hayallere ulaşmaya çalışan insanlar
dedim
ve o yüzden de benim bir hayali varsa
gelip bana anlatmasını çok isterim
anlatmaktan da çekinmezler tüm ekip
arkadaşlar gelirler Benim bir hayalim
var Evet o hayali yapabileceğimiz
ölçekte ayakları yere basan kocaman
Hayalci özgürlükle anlatmaları
bu süreçler beni biraz yordu ve insanlar
başka türlü nasıl yardım edebilirim
ölümleri görmek
Ta böyle katılmak istemiyorum sınırlar
var sınırları çizildiği yerde aşamadığın
Engeller var dedim ki evet bambaşka bir
şey kurmalıyım başka bir şey yapmalıyım
ve bunun ötesinde de
onurları kendi başvurmalıyım
ne yaparım ne yaparım internette
araştırdığımda koşarak bağış toplayan
beni ekibe denk geldim telefonla aradım
ya ben gönüllüyüm
lütfen organizasyonu İzmir ayağını ben
gerçekleştirebilirim
Neden peki Hayır Neden bunu Hayır
dediniz
daha çok popüler değil İzmir'de gönüllü
popüler değil gibi bu nedir öyle bir şey
olamaz diye böyle o sınır bana bir
engellenmek istemiyorum bunu yapmam
gerek burada yapmam gerekir Çünkü
engellenemem İzmir'de bir durum konuş
tu zaten bunda da kurmam için 6 ay
bekledik 6 ay sonunda da kuruduk oluşur
koşuyorsunuz koşarak bağış topluyorsunuz
Hani güzel değil mi koşarak hiçbir şey
yapmıyorsun insanları görmüyorsunuz
kimseyi incitmiyorsunuz ya bu hasta mı
diye bakmıyorsunuz sürekli bu ölecek mi
biliyor musunuz uğraşıyorsunuz ve bağışı
toplayıp vicdanen yatağa girdiğinizde
kendinizi rahatsız hissed
iyorsun peki dedim harika bu işi yaparız
burada yapamadık 8 ay boyunca tek başıma
gidip geldim bekledim saatlerim orada
geçirdim gelmedi sonra bir kişinin
gelmesiyle birlikte şimdi binlerce insan
İzmir'de burada birçok arkadaşım var
beraber koşuyoruz ve hayata destek
olmaya çalışıyorum
Bu benim sınırları Aştım sosyal
görünürlük ve sorumluluk kısmıydı Bir de
hayatımda şöyle bir durum oldu
genellikle
erkekler yapabilir kadınlar yapamaz
burada sınırlar Vardır her zaman
biliyorsunuz kadın olmak bu ülkede özür
diliyorum herkesten biraz daha zor Siz
başarılı bir yöneticiyi sevseniz kadın
olduğumuz için erkek çalışanlarını
sürdüğümde Ben şu an öyle bir durum
oluşabiliyor Eğer siz kadınsanız bir
şeyi yönetiyorsanız bir erkek gelir Evet
ya ben daha baskın bir karakterle bunu
daha iyi yapabilirim
zaten okey
[Müzik]
ne yapabilirim Çünkü sayısal zeka Ama
olabilir
[Müzik]
benim için başka bir yerde başka bir
devrim yaptığım bir konuydu bunları
yaparken de o dönemde birlikte olduğum
bir insan vardı ve şöyle
neden
Bu sana göre değil Bunu neden hayata
katmaya çalışıyorsun Daha başka yapacak
insanlar yok atıyorum konuşuyoruz
yerken kullanmak o oturuyor böyle bir
şeylerle ilgileniyor ve Ben duruyorum
yerken kullanmak için yeni bir lisans
açılmış online katılabilirdim
[Müzik]
benim Etrafımdaki insanlar bunu yapmaz
tüm kadınların hastalandığı şeyleri
içerisinde Ben de biliyorum acaba
yapabilir miyim yapamaz mıyım kendime
Benim var mı Evet sonrasında
hikaye boyunca tüm Türkiye'yi Eğer
kendine geziyorum Neden Çünkü
yapabilirim Neden Çünkü sınırlarım yok
Neden o sınırları her zaman
zaten
sınırlarımızda kendimizle ve
başkalarının sizi sınırlandırdığı
noktalara kalmış genetik
olarak genetik kodlar bizim bütün
ailemizden gelen çevremizde öğrenilmiş
çaresizlik olarak kullandığımız durumlar
bu öğrenip
biri size bu görselde güzeldir evet bu
görselde çirkindir Evet bunlardan
bahsediyorum ve biz bunu toplumun
normlarında kabul ediyoruz
içselleştiriyoruz ve artık onun doğru
olduğuna inanıyoruz
bir Kartalları da var bugüne kadar
devletler
flamalarında armalarında Kartalları
kullanmış parlak Kanatlar güzel siyah
bir beden bembeyaz hiç gagası
yakışıklılığı ki erkeğe benzetilir güç
Oradan gelir
bunu düşünmemiş
Kızıl gerdan
ama yeri geldiğinde bir kartaldan daha
fazla alabalık korumaya yöneliktedir
gelip o kartalı orada eğitmeye Şimdi her
şey çiğnemeye mutlu bir hayvan Biz Neyi
öğrendik kartalım ona Kartal güçlüdür
dedi değil
o kadar kötü çocuk biri vardı falan
kızım çok da gösterişli olmayan sadece
sempatik olan o kısım Birazdan bir
Kartal kadar olmamış gibi
değil Maalesef bu insani bakış açımızla
ilgili insani bakış açılarımızda bize
genetik kodlarımızdan geliyor bu genetik
kodların vereceğiz o işte Tamamen bizim
içimizde
bazıları reddettim biraz aykırıydım
biraz aktivistim ilk başta sivil topluma
Gönül vermek ve bunun üzerine çalışmak
sanıyor benim hayatımdaki en büyük dönüm
noktamdı Ben bir kızım geldi Belki çok
iyi gözükmeyen ufacık
türü hayatımı ele geçirmek konusunda Dur
bakalım deyip Kartalları arka falan
güzel bir yana sahip Sizler de o
sınırlarınızı korumayı o cam fanusun
içerisinden çıkmayı öğrenmek için her
günümüz özellikle yine kadınlardan örnek
vereceğim
Aynı ölçüde korumayı istiyorum Ama ne
yazık ki bu Orta Doğu coğrafyası Bizim
de bizim de
içerisinde bu Orta Doğu coğrafyası bizi
daha dişli o küçük Kızıl bir yerden
böyle daha savaşçı hale yöneltmeye
çalışıyor yapın Hayal kurup keşfedin
insanları söylediklerine kulak atmayın
ya Bu da delilik dediklerinde size Nigar
servantezi hayatım kendisi delilik biz
neredeyiz Biz daha da Deli olmalı daha
da enerjik olmalı daha da sınırlarımızı
vermemiz gerekiyor bu noktada son bir
hikaye ile bitirmek istiyorum size
bir işe girdim
hayatımınışı hala çalışıyorum
Kendi işimi yapıyorum harika bir firma
çalışıyoruz falan müdürüme gidip geldim
ama şey dedi
hiçbir şey olur musun
Allah Allah diye sordum eğitim yeterli
değil bugün o kadar görmüşsünüzdür
okulumuzu var
Bu çıldırmışım bir şeyler yapmışım malum
şu anlık verdi Sanırım yok almamdır
Nasıl yani Ama bunun bir gerekliliği var
mı bu şirkette çalışmak için yok benim
hayalimde diye sordunuz mu dedim Yok
sormadım Neymiş benim için dedi bundan
da iki taraf önce benim hayalim Niye o
siyahlı olmak bu şirkette Global bir
şirketle çalışıyordum 807 ülkede var
ve benim tek hayalim telefonum
peki falan dedi görüldü Sonra dedi ki
ülke müdürü olabilirmiş gibi Hayır zarın
okumadığım için ya da daha farklı Ziraat
Mühendisi olmadığım için asla olamaz
fayda eder hemen önce Ziraat okumak için
kolları sıvadım Onun öncesinde zaten
iklim krizlerine karşı gelen yollarda
akdenizce yürüyen bir görebilirsiniz
var nerede bir iklim yüzü var nerede
Pandalar suya düşermişlerdi
Balinalar yıkamamış Onların hepsi benim
orada koşarken balina çevriliyor balina
çiftliklerinin
özgürlük diye bağıran
çılgın bir arkadaştı
başladım tarım bitti ondan sonra da bir
toplantı esnasında dedi ki artık Genel
Müdürlük ve ülke müdürü için de olurum
ben bir tarafı
teknolojisi gerçekten Evet yapabilirim
saçmalık tekrar olamazsın
O zaman ben kendi onlar için
çalışıyorum onunla ilgili projeler
yapmaya başlıyorum yaklaşık 8 sene
boyunca
Bugün Türkiye'de gerçekleşen tarımı
nasıl birlikte örtüştürebilirim
önce herkes reddetti Çiftçilere gittim
arada Çiftçi olanlar var bilirler
sanırım lütfen
tarımsal yöntemlerle bana şunu söyledi
asla olmaz çok Terim istiyoruz bizim
darbemiz dünyaya lütfen
birisi bunu ters söylüyorum ben
[Müzik]
sonunda bugün Dünya en büyük firmaları
benim içerisinde bulunduğum çalıştığım
firmada daha iyi bana sen bir gün onu
önce söylediğimde sana İnanmadık ama şu
an her birimiz bu olay için tabii
her birimiz bu onarıcıları yapıyorum Ve
bu sene var dedi dünyada artık
Sürdürülebilir değil Onu arkaya yönelik
işleri yapıyoruz Bana da hafifçe
sahipten dolayı o küçük kız çocuğu
Hayallerinden dolayı teşekkür ediyorum
bu hayattaki en güzel şeylerden biridir
Umarım Sizler de benim gibi şanslı
olursunuz hayallerinize ulaşabilirsiniz
tüm kalbim
[Alkış]